So now, after the nomination of Amy CONI Barrett
to the Supreme Court and literally as the
New York Times story exposing Donald Trump's
taxes was breaking, Donald Trump held a press
briefing.
And this was a very haphazardly scheduled
press briefing.
It was Sunday.
In fact, Donald Trump was golfing when the
press briefing was scheduled just a few hours
before.
And although we don't know because they don't
tell us, it's reasonable to speculate that
a last minute press briefing scheduled on
a Sunday while Donald Trump is golfing may
well be to try to generate news and take attention
away from the breaking story in The New York
Times.
Also, a completely plausible that the Trump
administration knew it was going to be published
at least a few hours before it was published.
So, needless to say, Donald Trump holds a
press briefing and it's completely pathetic.
It's gaslighting.
It's delusional.
It's perverse.
Let's look at some of it.
Let's look at how dangerous this is.
Donald Trump still it's like he's taking attention
away from the tax story by saying horrible
authoritarian things.
Trump still won't commit to voluntarily leaving
office if he loses.
We all believe in transition, but not when
the system is rigged.
He says, now, I do apologize for the bad audio
quality of these clips.
Something was wrong with the audio in the
transmission.
It's not on our end.
But let's take a look at this first one, and
it's very dangerous for our country.
So certainly transition.
We believe in transition.
We believe not only in transition, but a very
friendly.
But when the ballots and when the system is
rigged, which it is, obviously it is.
And the only one that knows that better than
me or the Democrats.
And they go into closed rooms and they must
laugh like hell at what's going on because
these ballots are being thrown.
And this is the beginning.
I talk about it now at the rallies.
All those people are watching eyes and ears.
Thousands and thousands.
Tens of thousands.
But there's no justification for these extreme
changes to the election law.
He says when it's rigged and that it's rigged
this time, well, then it's a different situation.
You don't just commit to a peaceful transition
when it's rigged.
And he says it is indeed rigged.
Remember, there are no extreme changes to
election law the way he says.
All we've done is expand the list of valid
reasons for voting absentee in some states,
sending people an absentee ballot application
which they can fill out and send back if they
want an absentee ballot has been expanded.
But there have been no radical or extreme
changes.
So then the questions actually start about
the New York Times tax story and Trump first
just sort of weirdly denies it all, but doesn't
make any sense.
Completely collapsing under just basic questioning.
And listen to talk about these New York Times
story that came out about an hour ago that
says that when you came to the White House,
you were paying about 750 dollars a year in
federal income tax.
They are not releasing what?
They are not publishing tax.
Sir, does that sound right to her?
A couple hundred dollars a year in taxes?
Well, certainly Ms. It's totally fake news
made up.
So we went through the same stores.
You can arrest me.
The same questions.
Farmers are going to have to litigate this
and talk about it.
Totally fake news.
No, actually, I pay tax, but you'll see that
as soon as my tax returns.
It's underwrote it.
They've been under water for a long time.
The IRS does not treat me well.
They treat me like the Tea Party, like they
treated the Tea Party.
And they don't treat me well.
They treat me very badly.
Do you have people in the area?
The way they treat me very, very badly.
But they're under audit.
So Trump is asked about his taxes and he simply
says it's fake.
Now, I do think that eventually The New York
Times might have to figure out how do you
release the actual documents while protecting
the identity of their source.
So Trump can't keep calling it fake news.
For now, The New York Times has reported on
the contents of the tax documents, but they've
said we can't release the documents because
it would potentially expose our source.
And for now, Trump can say it's to speak at
some point.
If The New York Times can figure out how to
release the docs without endangering or exposing
their source.
That would be a good thing.
Then Trump is asked again about the taxes
and listen to how pathetically weak his pushback
is about the tax returns story that you have
to understand the way that Americans read
that you may have paid only a few hundred
dollars in federal income tax per year.
That seems very low for someone who's a billionaire.
So people are basically saying, I paid nothing.
If you give people an idea of how much you
actually are paying.
Yeah, basically.
Well, first of all, I've paid a lot and I
paid a lot of state income taxes to the New
York State, charges a lot.
And I paid a lot of money at stake.
It'll all be revealed.
It's going to come out.
But after the audit is after the break, how
much are you really paying?
He says, I'm paying a lot.
And, you know, I pay state taxes as well.
How interesting that now Trump has gone back
to this talking point of, oh, when my audits
are done, we're going to release the information,
which was what he said in 2015.
That's what he said in 2016.
And then, of course, just stopped saying once
he became president of the United States.
This story now, it's not forcing him to actually
disclose anything, but it has pushed him to,
again, go back to, well, once my audits are
done, we're going to disclose everything.
It's just complete gaslighting and anybody
who's falling for it at this point.
What planet have you been living on for the
last four years?
Donald Trump then was asked about does he
really think that Joe Biden is using drugs
to better perform during debates?
We'll talk about that a little bit later.
And Trump says, yeah, I'm not joking, which
we should know.
Trump doesn't tell jokes.
You said this numerous times.
Do you really believe that Joe Biden will
be on any type of performance enhancing drugs
out of the debates?
Or are you just joking?
No, no joking.
I mean, I'm going to take a drug test.
I think he should, too, because he's had a
very uneven.
I watched him with some of the when Tim was
worth debating Pocahontas in Harris, who treated
him so badly.
But I watched him and he was out of it.
Right.
I mean, I watched him against Bernie Sanders
that he was okay.
I mean, he wasn't great, but it wasn't terrible.
He was OK.
A far cry from the way he.
You know what I'm saying?
I mean, if you look at some of those debates,
I said there's no way he can continue.
He can't continue to do.
All of a sudden he debated crazy Bernie Sanders.
And you know what the truth is?
He was he was OK.
This is a president talking this way.
No other country at our level of development
or even below it would allow this.
And yet it's daily here in the United States.
And Trump continuing to push this.
Asked for sources on Joe Biden juicing, says,
oh, just look at the Internet.
A president asked for facts, says look at
the Internet.
OK.
And I said, how did he go from there to those
horrible performances to where he was?
Okay.
And that was a joke.
But, you know, it is true.
He was no Winston Churchill in debating.
But he was fine.
And people say he was on performance enhancing
drugs.
And a lot of people have said that.
A lot of people have written that.
So certainly, let's take a look.
Why don't you just check in and you can check
out the Internet.
You'll see plenty of people say it.
Now, finally, Trump is saying something true,
which is that you can find people on the Internet
saying, Biden use drugs.
You can find people on the Internet saying
the Earth is what you can find people on the
Internet saying Obama is a reptilian, not
of this earth.
Trump is finally right about something you
can find just about any nonsense you want
on the Internet.
And then Trump continuing to lie about his
crowd size.
Again, suggesting there were 30 or 35000 people
at a recent rally.
There were 4000 people there, remember that,
general, that I don't know if it would have
been reported before.
But all of these rallies, those with thousands
of people last night, as you know, and we're
in Harrisburg, Pennsylvania, the night before
we were in Virginia.
I mean, those KRETZER well, there was 35000,
30000.
Those crowds are massive.
And that's on very short notice.
All of those people are watching.
You know, we have eyes and ears now that we
wouldn't have had if we didn't bring it up.
So, no, I'm sure she's watching and I'm sure
that everybody's looking at it.
I think I think it's just common sense.
Go ahead.
It's just lie about the big stuff.
Lie about the small stuff.
Lie all the time.
And then one more thing.
This every every time this happens, it's it's
just a reminder that presidents sometimes
can talk about policy.
Trump can't.
Trump was asked about the conflict between
Armenia and Azerbaijan, and he can do nothing
other than to say we're looking at it very
strongly.
It's it's a meme now.
But that's actually what he said.
Mr President, I was totally surprised, you
know, that you have to have a little taking.
There has been no military action in fighting,
whereas the comment on the civilians are killed,
according to the officials from Gaza.
They say the first group came from.
What's your problem?
So we're looking at it very strongly.
Just happened.
And I know about it.
I learned about it today and yesterday.
Then we're looking at it very strongly.
We have a lot of good relationships in that
area.
We'll see if we can stop it.
Thank you very much.
Of the previous 50 years before the 2016 elections,
you played zero dollars, just 25, unable to
speak in depth about any issue.
So this is now maybe the story through the
election or maybe not.
Is this the October surprise?
The Trump tax story that came a few days early?
Or is something even crazier going to break
between now and the election?
I don't even I don't even have any interest
nor ability to guess anything could happen.